Love Is in the Air for Zoe Kravitz and
Channing Tatum and Now Zoe is opening up
about their relationship for the first
time truly happy to be here the
lovebirds met on the set of her upcoming
directorial debut Pea Island and Now Zoe
tells GQ that the two had an instant
connection quote he's just a wonderful
human he makes me laugh and we both
really love art and talking about art
and the exploration of why we do what we
do we love to watch a film and break it
down and talk about it and challenge
each other I can tell you it's
incredible I
I'm in awe she's just killing it
Channing made his directorial debut with
dog maybe we could have some fun is that
a deal Jake
Zoe says he was on hand to help her
navigate her first time in the
director's chair quote whether it was
making me tea or pouring me a drink or
going to whip someone into shape or
whatever he really was my protector and
it was really wonderful and sweet I
think if you can do something like that
together it's a good test and we came
out even stronger I'm really blessed man
when ET caught up with Channing back in
February he admitted he advised Zoe not
to direct and star in the film something
he did with dog well I know you gave Zoe
some advice on it too is that what you
said to her like don't do both just
direct I just don't think you enjoy it
like I didn't get to enjoy really
directing figuring out the next shots
and like what the next decisions are and
like what they're getting and you know
I'm sort of in my own little world over
there and I just I I think that it's you
need twice the time if you're going to
be in the movie and in February Zoe told
E.T she was glad she listened to her man
I'm absolutely not starring in on in
that film it's hard enough to to act on
on your own I don't know how people do
both I will not be in the movie I'll
just be directing it one thing at a time
the two first turned heads back in 2021
when they were spotted riding through
the streets of NYC on a joint bike ride
and Zoe recalls that at that moment she
knew the cat was out of the bag
you got a lot of cats
never think about Strays well you want
to keep it sacred and private as long as
you can so that you don't have to even
think about what the world thinks about
it this is Zoe's first romance since her
split from her ex-husband Carl Glassman
the former couple ended their
relationship after 18 months of marriage
back in 2021 and in March Channing was
right by his leading lady's side at the
premiere of herflick the Batman
alongside Jason Momoa Zoe's stepdad two
of your guys and your fam giving you a
shout out what does it mean to have them
in your corner giving you that support
well you know we're in New York tonight
and I live here I have a lot of friends
and family here tonight so I feel very
lucky to have a lot of people who love
me
[Music]
foreign